all right welcome back to safety blitz
you know rodney harrison jack
collinsworth so this is the nfc side of
things now you got the 49ers you have
the rams and this is a little big
brother little brother right shanahan
and mcveigh they've worked together
before but shanahan has been big brother
and he has been playing like it they
have won six straight against the rams
dating back to 2019. what do you think
about first looking at this matchup in
the championship game
well i think about the physicality of
the san francisco 49ers man and i've
always said if you want to beat the rams
you have you have to beat them up at the
line of scrimmage control the line of
scrimmage and if you can do that you
will win a lot of football games we saw
san francisco do it multiple times we
saw the tennessee titans do it you just
have to play a physical style of
football but on the other side if you're
the rams you have to continue to try to
run the football it can't be all matthew
stafford 30 40 passes you can't do that
you have to continue to get those tight
ends involved
sony michelle cam akers continue to run
the football keep him off balance and
see what happens there
i think the afc is a straight shootout i
think this one's a little more knock
down drag out low scoring all about
defenses the one that could really screw
up the 49ers if trent williams because
he looked one-legged looked a little
one-legged bum ankle he has in about mid
third quarter late third quarter of that
game he was just starting to limp around
a bit and if he's not healthy between
von miller and a.d and floyd all the
different people that you're gonna have
to face with the rams it could become
very problematic that's the one issue i
think tebow sam was gonna be fine he
just got banged and had to limp over the
sideline apparently started feeling
better pretty quickly he's a little sore
bruised knee whatever the case may be
but i'm a little more worried about
trent williams because if he doesn't
have that pop like we're used to seeing
from him i could see that pass rush
being a major issue for jimmy g
no question you talking about the best
left tackle in all of football the
meanest the meanest the baddest dude and
he you talk about the pass rush just
getting at them rams
von miller you know aaron donald these
guys just getting after them and and you
know what
that's who they're gonna have to block
they're gonna have to block von miller
he does such a great job not only
getting to the quarterback but in the
run game then you got leonard floyd
who's 6'5 coming off the edge and they
just consistently ashawn robinson just
put pressure on you in the middle of the
pocket i'm excited man this is going to
be a heck of a match-up
it really is it really is man it's it's
it's all comes down to these teams that
can get after the passer and like von
miller to me looks fresh right now it's
kind of funny how some of these guys
that you know vaughn had that knee
injury where he got about three or four
weeks off right there in the middle of
the season then he had the rams week 11
bye week at the end of it so he sort of
got that spring break if you will in the
middle of the season and it's just funny
to me how some of these guys with how
long the season is now you got the
playoffs on the tail end of it the push
to the super bowl the guys who have just
gotten a little built-in rest how much
fresher they look than some of these
other it's almost survive it's like who
can survive who can get some of their
best players at this point in the year i
mean you saw george kittle limping off
late you saw debo samuel limping off
late you saw trent williams just trying
to battle through it i mean these are
wars on these football fields these guys
are just trying to make it out and
trying to make it to the next one so can
they beat bionic and go do it again
that's the question because the 49ers
were definitely a little limping by the
end of it
you talked about stanford you talked
about the rams having like this sense of
urge urgency they're hungry and whatever
they are and you think about aaron
donald you know you matter of fact you
think about von miller and when von
miller was in denver he felt like he had
to do everything by himself chubb was
always hurt he felt like he had to do
everything by himself he comes over here
and he's like oh my goodness look at all
these guys i got the best defensive
player on the planet right there i got
leonard floyd coming off the edge and we
got some other rotational guys inside
that we can play and fit in so he didn't
feel like when he came to the rams that
he had to be this special player he just
felt like he could just be himself and
go out there and play and that's what
he's doing it's not like he's doing
anything special he's just being von
miller where he doesn't have to do
everything he has other guys helping
them out especially in the secondary
when you get that you get that secondary
they can cover they can play zone read
and react or they can play man you got
jalen ramsey come on man
it's a great point you got to give
credit to mcveigh in this front office
for just infusing this talent late odell
beckham jr von miller it's just giving
fresh life and energy to that group
where a lot of teams you feel them even
the bucks you feel them starting to come
down right then you've got a team like
the rams who's getting hot at the right
time and that's what it's become about
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports